al-jazeera's aina holla as you can see
is is out on the streets among the
demonstrators zina bring us up to speed
with what's been happening there and
where you are which really is the
epicenter of the protest movement you
can see tear gas falling security forces
trying to disperse the crowd because
argument building is not very far from
where we are standing approximately two
three hundred meters from where we are
because of the water because of the tear
gas protesters had no choice but to move
towards martyr square where we are now
running battles in the streets we've
seen more and more incidents like this
over recent days as anger grows as
frustration grows you can see it's very
difficult for us to approach at the
moment because we're not wearing any gas
masks but the smell really of tear gas
has engulfed this whole area in downtown
Beirut this is the heart of the Lebanese
capital a few days ago there were
incidents of violence outside of police
barracks where security forces were
holding a number of activists who are
protesting the detention of their
friends the day before that Commerce
Street a commercial district in the
capital was a war zone so Lebanon really
the economy is in near collapse and that
is why you are seeing this people
returning to the streets this this
escalation we are day five of the
so-called week of rage which activists
announced on Tuesday they promised to
step up protest action to force those in
power to resign but the biggest question
is
it's protest like this got to be enough
to force them to leave power to give up
political power which they have held for
three decades most of those politicians
empower our warlords very lebanon's a
civil war how bigger this crowd of
protesters how in number how does it
compare to those who are out on the
streets in the early days of the
protests four months ago
in the early days of the protest
movement there were tens of thousands of
people it was a nation nationwide
protests cross sectarian and that was
really what made it very very different
people from various
[Music]
reasons where they benefit from those
parties that these politicians give them
jobs especially in the public sector so
yes people are calling this an uprising
against the political class duty to
force the political class which has been
in power for decades really to leave but
there is an equal number of people who
stay asleep in their homes
who still want to support those in power
because they either like I told you they
either benefit from them or for
ideological reasons they still support
them others are afraid of the
alternative because this leaderless
protest movement it has not really
presented much of an alternative apart
from one we want the transitional
government an independent government
that will govern the country until early
elections so there are still a lot of
people who are still not convinced on
what what this protest action will
achieve whether it will just create more
anarchy in the country the police have
been firing teargas canisters musing
water cannon against the protesters the
presses themselves though appear to have
come prepared for trouble I mean they're
throwing fireworks you can hear them
going off in the background there where
how did the trouble start was it did the
police fire first was it always did the
protesters come looking to trouble
so we were watching this live on
television protestors were attempting to
break the security barrier outside
Parliament building
they were provoking the security forces
they were throwing firecrackers and
stones and security forces responded the
internal security forces also released
the statement an hour ago calling on
what they call quote the peaceful
protesters to leave the area if they do
not want to get hurt but the internal
security forces are saying is that what
they believe is that there are some
infiltrators who want to instigate
violence and they do not want the
peaceful protestors to be caught up in
the middle some other areas today the
protest action was caught and it was
being called afro to Parliament they
called on people from across the country
to get on buses to get in their cars and
to converge here in downtown Beirut
outside Parliament Square to put the
pressure to maintain the pressure on the
political in need to leave office so a
lot of people who are here and I must
say we are still in a few thousand I
wouldn't say more than a few thousand
they came here to really do do something
a lot of people are saying well our
peaceful protests are not getting
anywhere those in power are not
listening to us they are not listening
to our demands they are not listening to
our concerns we are becoming more poor
to survive we're losing our jobs the
unemployment rate is on the rise we have
no other choice but to find a way out of
the country which they don't want to do
so this is why you're sitting this
escalation in the past few days no we
cannot not discuss what is going on on
the political level because first of all
there's a political vacuum in the
country the Prime Minister side of
Hariri he resigned back in October
amid the nationwide protests in
mid-december a new prime minister was
appointed but he was appointed by the
ruling Alliance they have no interest in
being the next cabinet they are saying
that they're going to need the call of
the street and they don't want any
ministers in the in the next government
so now the politicians who are bickering
over seats come from the ruling Alliance
and they're bickering with the man they
appointed they no longer want him so
some people who are in the streets today
are supporters of the ruling Alliance
who would like to put pressure on the
man they appointed Hassan Dib to leave
office it's a very complicated picture
and that's Lebanon it's the sectarian
based political system it's very hard
for the different sects to come together
where everyone feels that they are a
part of the nation because when a
certain sex feels marginalized then that
is where you see them take protest
action in the street does it say a
complicated picture and that's Lebanon
al-jazeera Zana hora out on the streets
there in central Beirut as any we'll be
back with you a little later let's bring
it Rami Khouri
journalism professor at the American
University of Beirut he joins us now via
Skype from Beirut Rami quite remarkable
scenes there in the center of town what
do you make of this this is a real
important turning point in this whole
uprising revolution revolution as
the protesters call it a few days ago
there was a pretty clear movement
towards forming a new government Hassan
idea had picked 18 allegedly independent
technocratic people to become ministers
and then the protesters discovered that
in fact six or seven of these were very
close to one of the political parties in
the in the new government and they were
very upset people very upset that they
thought they were being taken for a ride
that in fact this new government of
alleged technocrats
was really just a smokescreen for the
old ruling oligarchic elite and the
arguments between them as then I said
was about who was going to get the share
of government portfolios that they
expect so the protesters were really
upset and then at the same time about
two three nights ago you had some small
protest just a couple hundred people in
Hamra Street Hamra Street is like the
you know the the Oxford Street or the
region street of of Beirut it's a very
famous old commercial center and the
people some demonstrators were out from
the Central Bank
others were smashing back windows and
smashing a couple of ATM machines and
and this seemed to have struck a chord
with the political elite that the banks
were actually being hit as a symbol
because the the banks have become a
symbol for everything that's wrong in
Lebanon because people can't get their
money and they're in their own accounts
they're not allowed to take out all
their money or even much of it I just
went to the bank this morning and took
out my weekly three hundred dollars and
five hundred thousand Lebanese which is
which is around maybe two hundred
dollars in Lebanese you're allowed a
certain amount every week to take out
from your own account so people have
been the protesters have gotten really
angry and the political elite has struck
back and so this is a high-tension
moment in Lebanon
frustration by all sides that we're
getting nowhere and in the meantime as
Xena said everybody is suffering
ordinary people can't get their money
people are losing jobs prices are rising
and basic things that people have to do
like have medical operations or pay
their children's education fees they're
having trouble or they can't do it so
there's a real real sort of existential
fear among many people in the meantime
the daily life those aren't people go to
work people go to their religious
centers people go to school but there's
a lot of tension and and they probably
the big change in the last week has been
the willingness of the authorities to
use force on the street to break up
demonstrators the authorities say that
there's they're just trying to stop
these hooligans who are going out to
cause trouble yeah you say that right at
the beginning of that answer you said
that this is a turning point in what way
man apart from registering people's
anger and as you say causing trouble a
it seems that a that these protesters
have come to you know prepared for
trouble in what way is this a turning
point there what can it this achieve
well it's a turning point because I
think it shows us the continually rising
fear among both both parties the
ordinary people who are protesting and
the political elite that is trying to
maintain its hold on power using the
formation of the new government which is
supposed to be a technocratic
independent government but using that to
essentially cement and maintain they
hold on government and power and and
privilege that they have had for decades
and decades so both sides are really
worried about what's going on and they
want to try to achieve their own goals
the the 30 point is that there's been an
escalation and both the protests both of
which all of which are peaceful except
for a few
occasional troublemakers who and nobody
knows if these troublemakers are sent by
some of the political forces to stir
things up or if they're just a bunch of
young kids who are like in all
situations like this they go out and
they they destroy things but both the
demonstrators and the political elite
are are frightened and they're acting in
this way but the real the new element is
the willingness of the authorities to
use force - today - as they say maintain
public order and of course everybody
wants to maintain public order when Bank
machines were being smashed and Bank
facades were being broke glass facades
were being smashed that's kind of scared
a lot of people and people were starting
to worry maybe even I'm not gonna be
able to get my $300 a week now if this
goes on but today's demonstration was
supposed to be the culmination of a week
the fanger as it was called a week of
rage and people were coming in from
buses early in the morning from the
north in the south and all over the
country so I would anticipate that we're
gonna see tomorrow some more large-scale
demonstrations peaceful demonstrations
as they mostly have been and it I
wouldn't be surprised if they if they
call a curfew or something or they
prevent demonstrations downtown because
this is really scaring people when you
get this level of violence even though
the numbers are relatively small we're
not talking of thousands and thousands
of people who are shooting each other
you've got probably a couple of hundred
people who were out on the front lines
throwing stuff at the police and then
done that police firing back people also
were upset by the manner in which the
police have put down the demonstrations
the two three nights ago about 50 60
young people were arrested there was
videos of them being dragged on the
street they were taken to police
stations and arrested for a couple of
nice people that went to the police
stations and peacefully demonstrated
outside demanding to get these people
out a few reporters were beaten up and
they
the hospitals they were filmed in the
hospital and again Madame kiss was
earth-shaking stuff but it was quite
dramatic yeah
and relatively new and that's why you're
seeing what you're seeing now professor
it's always good to talk to you many
thanks indeed Rami Khouri there in
Beirut thank you for your insight al
Jazeera's a Lahore is out among that
chaos that we've been washing this years
as they know what's going on around here
right now here so security forces really
seem to be very determined to clear this
whole area from the protesters as you
can see a few hundred people within
people who were initially outside the
Parliament building they attempted to
storm Parliament building when security
forces responded with tear gas and water
cannon so people are now in martyrs
square tear gas landing close by we also
understand that the other side of the
square what is known as we have a select
square outside the government palace
there too there are running battles
between security forces and protesters
so as you can see the state is
determined to end
this is what protesters how protesters
are fighting back people here really are
very very determined and they've come
from across Lebanon they're not just
people who live in Beirut okay they have
faith in the state they've lost trust in
the state
they've lost trust in their politicians
who are bickering amongst themselves on
deciding who gets what ministry instead
of solving the economic crisis in the
country the country is in near economic
collapse for the first time in two
decades the Lebanese pounds the local
currency devalued on the black market up
to 50 percent of the value of the
Lebanese pounds which means the
purchasing power it means that the
purchasing power of the Lebanese state
has lost purchasing power no longer very
very difficult you heard what Romney
said they cannot access their deposits
in the bank I'm sorry we have to move a
bit back in order to be able to talk and
breathe because of the smell of tear gas
so the people feel that the banks are
rubbing them that the state is rubbing
them from their own money and this is
wrong
you're seeing this escalation over the
past few days yes there was a loan there
was a love for a few weeks there are a
number of reasons why there was a brief
role in this uprising or what people
here if you ask them they call it their
revolution they say to zero
thank you people holding sticks it's
it's tense it's tense people feel some
local media inside with another tense
times in Lebanon so now you said this is
the culmination of a this is a
combination of a week of protests a week
of Rage talk us through what has
happened throughout this week
I'm sorry Adrian it's very difficult to
eat then if you need some some time
that's okay I think we let me talk for a
while obviously there's a lot of tear
gas in the air down there in Central
Beirut and it's very difficult to
breathe as soon as and her crew are
trying to move away from the epicenter
of those protests where all the tear gas
is it's still there's so much tear gas
in the air that it's still pretty hard
to work to walk and talk to us at at the
same time but these then live pictures
from Central Beirut e-even excuse me
where police have been firing tear gas
and water cannon at protesters for quite
a few hours now those protesters have
been demanding a speedy resolution to
the country's financial and economic
crisis hundreds possibly thousands owner
was saying of people are involved in
running battles with security forces the
demonstrators displaying their anger as
we were hearing from Rami Khouri a
little earlier over plans by the ruling
party to form a government which is
essentially made up of a verse from the
current political class it comes at the
end the combination of a week of rage
after that been a lull in these four
months protests four months of protests
now in Beirut and it appears that
frustration is boiling over and it
appears very much as though the
protesters tonight on the streets of
Beirut 'add had come prepared for
trouble looking for trouble because as
Zena
was saying and Rami coolly a little bit
career little earlier that people are
are so frustrated people are losing jobs
they can't even access their their own
money
in the the banks their banks are
limiting that withdrawals of cash
professor Corey was telling us that he'd
been today to withdraw his five hundred
dollars worth of cash and that's all
that he's allowed to to have for for a
week so once again live pictures from
downtown Beirut where we're looking at
here I think of fireworks being thrown
by the protesters at the police who've
responded with tear gas and water cannon
cannon and the ubiquitous laser pens
they're streaking through the sky
I mean illuminating the tear gas you can
see how much tear gas is in the sky and
we've got designer back there we've just
got can he resign or a couple of a
couple of moments before we need to take
a break
hopefully there's a little clear away
you are now
yes apologies Adriene as you can imagine
it's very hard to speak and breathe
really because of the smell of tear gas
we've been that we we've been really
we're now on the edge of martyrs Square
where most of the protesters are now the
security forces really is really using a
lot of teargas to try to disperse the
crowd to move them away from this whole
area it's not clear if people are in how
long these running battles will continue
we've seen scenes like this over the
past few days they usually lasts for a
few hours before security forces are
able to contain the unrest in previous
occasions security forces did not just
use tear gas and water cannon they use
excessive force they beat up protesters
they made arrests and they really came
under a lot of criticism by human rights
groups that they used excessive force to
disperse the crowds this really is a
message from those in power those in
power that we will not allow you to
storm public buildings we will not not
allow you to destabilize the situation
but Lebanon is already destabilized
there is a political vacuum there's
economic turmoil as you can hear the
ambulances coming in and going out we
understand a lot of riot police
anti-riot police were injured you've
been here you've been here since they
weren't why this escalation now we've
seen you here since October 17 you
haven't left the street why because we
don't have social justice in this
country we have nothing life at this
point life at this point is not
it's not worth living if this doesn't
change and we are in the common
economical crisis our system has they
just proved their service how much of a
failure they are in every single way we
have no ministry working we have nothing
we have nothing
people are dying right but do you think
do you think this is Kevin is this this
do you think that any change can happen
there's no way it's been it's been
almost 100 days
nobody's listening they're still forming
the same shitty government we first
thought you I'm sorry but this is how it
is we don't want to use the cursing word
but once they've been doing is crime
they've then they're criminals
we we are ruled by criminals we're
warlords they've done the Civil War and
they still doing us ok but do you really
think I mean do you have all the support
that you need no there's still people
whose report those in power
how would you can have a you're gonna
convince them to side with you and put
it in order they put enough we are in an
economical crisis everybody's gonna get
hungry everybody's gonna eat the leaders
soon enough I don't have to convince
anybody about what's happening today
it's clear what's happening who can get
a hold of their money in the banks who
has electricity in their homes who has
water how can you breathe this oxygen
that we're breathing now how could you
be with them we've seen everything
burning and going down to the ground
unless this sitting delusional urgent we
have the delusional people they go up
they say their speech but but the
argument is you cannot topple the result
of a parliamentary election that
happened in 2018 from the street where
we saw most of the voting's and the
trashman's I have people who can come
and prove people who actually were voted
to be MP and who woke up and they're no
longer MPs what are you what are you
promising next I mean they're fighting
back what can you do next I mean here
with all of your fight with all of your
friends how what are you gonna do next
we cannot stand like this seeing the
people the politicians doing nothing we
cannot we have 5000 years of history it
is an amazing country they took
everything we have nothing left this is
why our only option is to go down on the
street and ask violence we have to use
violence
[Music]
without collateral damage we cannot win
if we don't lose we have to lose well to
sacrifice we have when you first took to
the streets I remember you were all
chanting peaceful peaceful who worked
like we are people he's a father I'm an
artist like like like it's not we didn't
want to confront nor we can confront
like today I was putting my caste and I
didn't know how to do it I looked at the
at the cup I'm like like damn you I
don't even know how to put my defense
like 100 what are the politicians resort
to violence in order to achieve their
goals at the beginning I do remember and
I used to see these same protesters in
the streets saying that there's the only
way for it is to use peaceful means we
are not going to be drawn into any
conflict but but you didn't see the
anger people don't feel that they have
any future in their own country accusing
really the politicians of taking from
the people and not giving anything in
return and there's barely any basic
services in this country they mentioned
the electricity nobody has electricity
people are forced to pay two bills you
have the 17th there was a proposal to
tax what's up calls which should be free
and that really was the tipping point
for many people especially it came just
a few days after wildfires the
authorities were unable to put out wild
fires because the equipment they didn't
have the emergency equipment that they
needed to do that so so Adrian you can
see the anger for yourselves people
expressing their frustration and they're
growing impatient with the politicians
in power
al-jazeera's a Nahanni reporting live
from central beirut for the moment
hosannah many thanks indeed if you've
just joined us this is al-jazeera with
continuing coverage of events in central
beirut where police are firing tear gas
and water cannon of protesters who are
demanding a speedy resolution to the
country's financial and economic crisis
hundreds of protesters have been
involved in running battles with
security forces the demonstrators angry
over plans by the ruling party to form a
government from the current political
class joining us now on the line is one
of those protesters mere a2e
mayor we spoke to you what some 4050
minutes ago where are you right now
what's going on around you right now I'm
Nexus I see
it's a few meters have moved
significantly from the area of nearby
Dept and right now everybody has
scattered in the areas next to democracy
plans to move towards possibly nice be
square which is a
the other side of the Parliament the
teachers the bomb were too much to
handle the protesters had to really move
significantly from the area where there
was a lot of people who were fainting
due to the two judges and the police
were chasing some of the protesters in
two different anyways
nearby the Parliament area next to and
the HAR newspapers the protesters now
are indifferent we're trying to recover
from the teachers bomb with an intention
to go back in when things have come down
a bit but definitely the cases between
the police and the protesters continue
Mia why are people so angry they're in
Beirut tonight commented on this but
it's been 94 days there has been no
response from the government with
regards to the process to the demands of
the revolution and continuously the
government do not i also there are plans
to form a government that is not fit
with the demand and that the people have
been speaking about for the last 94 days
people have are becoming more and more
economically decisions every day people
are starving people are hungry people
are angry at the situation that we're
living in while we were down there we
were hearing that actually they were
trending so much water but the water
just serving on earth and there are
people receives any water to their home
for the past eight days and the area of
Beirut not to mention all of the other
right basically human rights of people
are not sitting in recovery from water
to help them I care to electricity so
really people have all of this has been
automation for a really long time right
now and people are saying that this is
their only chance to get the rights and
from the government how long are you
prepared to stay out on the streets Mir
thank you for a few more hours I guess
until we can no longer hold the ground
but for so far
the numbers have been enormous usually
when these kinds of things happen
protesters tend to shy away from the
violence that's taking place right now
what you're still seeing hundreds of
people still holding to Johnson now all
right Mia many thanks indeed Mia to
either one of the protesters as you can
see on the streets there of Beirut the
streets that are thick with tear gas and
the smoke from fireworks that are being
thrown by other protesters still with us
is Rami Khouri
journalism professor at the American
University of Beirut he's with us via
Skype from the city what did you make of
what we've heard in the last 15 minutes
or so those protests are saying that
life is not worth living they've nothing
left to lose they took everything and
and what Mir was saying just a moment is
here ago they've got water for the water
cannon but not for people's homes in
Beirut yes that's right and this is a
typical of what many of the protesters
are saying and not just that young
people aren't on the streets but a lot
of middle aged and older people and
people all over the country are really
totally exasperated by what they feel is
the disdain by which their own
government treats them that we've had
this terrible crisis economically now
for months and months but there's been
three months of protests and there's
there are very few statements by
government ministers talking about the
economy the value of the Lebanese leader
essential issues there the government
barely talks to the people and this is
what angers them people have this sense
of not just helplessness but almost
dehumanization that they're not treated
like human beings by their own
government it's not a you know foreign
occupying power or a colonizing power or
military invasion from abroad which
happens all over the region and has
happened here this is your own people in
in your own country so you have really
now this incredible convergence of two
very strong forces the anger rage
and desperation of probably a majority
of the population though they're not all
out of the streets and at the same time
the same kind of fear among the
political elite that desperate
desperately wants to stay in power and
is trying to carry our policies that
they think will help them stay in power
if they make just symbolic reforms and
changes and you can see it in the
symbolism of the slogans there was
demonstrations I attended a few to see
what's going on the other day near the
University and the slogans that people
use they say down with the rule of the
security state down with the rule of the
banks down with the rule of the central
bank there they're really expressing
extreme anger at these authorities who
they see as being in cahoots with each
other the banking system and the
political elite were working to it's
hard to tell where this is going to go
by the way what you're seeing in Lebanon
is very typical of what you're seeing in
Iraq in Sudan in Algeria and in other
countries where you have similar
situations each one a little bit
different particular in its own
situation but the driving forces of
political anger economic stress and
psychological dehumanization those
forces are all common throughout this
region and that's why you've got
demonstrations going on now almost
non-stop for the last nine ten years
across the majority of Arab countries
and it's really the question of who has
authority who who sets the rules and who
benefits from the government system and
this is not going to be decided on the
streets ultimately it's going to be
decided in a political showdown and
nobody knows how it's going to turn out
in love it and what you need is a
serious mediator here to step in as
happened in Sudan and Sudan made a
credible transformation with a Governing
Council which has one more civilian
the military this is historic Lebanon is
going to have to go through something
similar where the political elite and
the citizens come to some agreement
about how to make a transition now to
resolve the pressing economic and
technical issues like energy garbage
water let alone jobs or the value of
your money all of these are each one of
these is a big issue and they're all
pressing on people simultaneously and
when people see that the the government
is able to be so decisive
when it comes to putting their protests
but is totally undecisive in terms of
addressing that the real stresses that
impact the millions of people that's
what really gets them angry